louder with crowder studios protected
exclusively by walter
and hopper
neglected by the system in a world of
d-platforming
and bogus hate-speech guidelines ain't
nobody care about us
until one teacher so why should we even
try and fight it holmes
changed everything because there's
nothing
cool about letting them
silence you as i watch all the channels
that are going through hell i have to
ask them because in my
class free speech is its own reward
and you don't have to go through life a
victim that's a choice you come and live
in my neighborhood for one week and then
you tell me if you got a choice
that little youtube wanna put till i
serve em in the night have asian in the
street
you have to rage against the dying of
the light
damn it you promised you'd fight back if
matt's life is going to be worth a damn
you better give me your best i need your
best don't have that kind of cash just
laying around like usa
and your friends six feet under already
made theirs damn it why was your age we
didn't have mug clubs we didn't have
anything like mud club i would have
killed for mug club but we have it now
we have it now because it's 2016 damn it
it is 2016.
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up jorge
this 2018 dangerous
mugs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ah that's the guy who rolled the dice by
having a terrorist in his studio
and it came up is it snake what is snake
eyes bad
i think that guys are good it depends on
the game i don't know i have no idea
uh it serves at the sound of the weekend
thank you so much for being here and uh
like i was saying in third chair today
we have mahmoud al-mahmood
director of communications and public
relations for isis
good to see you stephen glad to have you
back see you here we hope that you see
the softer side of isis
i dwell i will do my best today i'm here
to kill you with kindness uh i see what
you did there i see but uh and also
actually kill me i believe
well you know eventually eventually it's
a long shot these are
he's uh and then we have
we have we have larry the cable guy on
the show today uh
because you know someone sent a bomb
yeah and they thought it was actually it
thought it was one of your flags it
turned out to be getter done flag
did you see that no no i didn't i
we use arabic you guys say that all the
time i don't know when to believe you
are yeah well that could be what isis is
credit for it well like a frat boy who
farts
we take credit immediately uh edgy
mortgage didn't bring any wine today
protesting all the things and quarter
black of course producing first so
question of the day
there's no black twitter it's called
world star uh the
question of the day who okay who got it
worse tucker carlson or jim acosta
right and do you think either of them
had it coming because i think the answer
might tell us who you are are you really
offended by the jim acosta scenario is
there an equivalent i've been seeing
this on twitter people like well you
know you think it's okay to revoke
jim acosta's press badge so then it's
okay to do the uh
kill the beast there at tucker carlson's
house ramming down his oak door
i am i am it's remarkable uh listen of
course right off the bat i want to
address the uh the thousand oaks uh
shooting at at the time of this taping
we don't know exactly what's happened
i lived in moorpark for a while out
there in the valley uh close to
thousands looks beautiful great people
so my heart goes out to them not enough
info um to really talk about and i don't
really want to go to the gun control
issue right now
you know because i used to say it's a
winning issue for the right i i actually
uh
i can't it's one done they make no
headway
on gun control when these issues happen
so i it's it's like feeding it to
feeding a tumor just let it let it die
just don't look yeah what's
what is the isis opinion on american gun
control you know uh
we are going to just sit with this one
out good
uh guns you know if you guys have guns
you want to shoot each other with guns i
don't see why we're going to stop it
okay i said oh jesus wise person i don't
know about the killing with kindness all
right
leading us before that you good girl
what was this you're doing this with
your lips yeah that had a thing
okay it's almost like a baseball leaving
the news uh i guess uh today
well the least surprising news of the
week jim acosta finally hasn't
had white house potentials pulled the
decision came after the now of course
notorious standoff between him
and president uh donald trump during
press conference wednesday when he
wouldn't give the microphone back to an
intern
now of course listen on the right or
most on the right see this
as a given while those on the left see
this as donald trump driving his final
nail into the coffin
of modern journalism
[Applause]
it seems my life
is gonna
[Music]
we do not have the rights to that song
by the way but no one does and it's like
no one really cares
yeah look the the most dangerous place
to be is between jim acosta and a news
camera right
that's when he's doing reporting but at
the same time when when obama i'm sorry
when trump
said to him i just channeled obama's are
you
used to quit caffeine all right i'm
gonna give you one more chance to wake
up here
morgan no whatever it is everyone in the
studio come on let's get it that's
confusing obama yeah let's do the west
side story we're not doing it
that's right you have to do that pick it
up all right so all right trump said
that he was like
a person right but he said he was a
despicable person i was like
you kind of crossed the line there yeah
look reporters are supposed to be jerk
sometimes
you don't you don't get mad at them for
that you can pull their credentials and
he can go back there
he just doesn't have a hard pass they
have to reissue it now so no big deal
right i think it's i thought it was
perfect and i'm not necessarily a huge
donald trump but i loved where he goes
why did you call the caravan an invasion
well that's what i that's what i think
that's how i see it that's how i see i
see it as an invasion he goes well you
think it was inflammatory
no that's called a difference of a
pigeon okay
he backed it up zero oh my gosh i mean
backed off
zero now you've got it to me you've got
it what do you have that is it that bug
that you picked off the toilet
joe rogan was talking about the idiocy i
don't know i don't know
are you still doing well in my mood you
seem confused yeah i you know i just
want to say that none of this stuff with
the
drama in the press room would happen if
gary johnson won
that's true you got let's see this is
what you guys don't have free press you
don't have any of these issues right
people just get shot
uh well yeah sadly but uh i'm just
saying you know
johnson president we're not talking
about this it's gonna be a nice happy
place
mostly because he's a late and
homosexual and that's not that not
saying he couldn't hold
office and we'll talk about this uh
later we'll get we're doing a vox
rebuttal because ours was so fun this
week where they say more women need to
be nominated because
um but gary johnson always seemed very
gay to me i don't know why you can
comment let me know i don't think i
don't know but
about that but it is about time that
america elects a president who doesn't
know where aleppo
is that's speaking from the heart
all right in more seriousness that would
be a good cover for you advantageous
that's that's that is
very selfish i see it it's almost as
though you have ulterior motives more
serious news of course this week uh um
another man was injured uh by uh yet
another exploding bottle of corona
uh this has been going on for a while
this is actually the third man i have
the
third man in recent months to say a
corona bottle exploded while he was
handling it causing a gruesome injury
uh the quote is he said it's like
they're selling glass hand grenades now
there's been no official explanation
explanation so you
just screw you stop being so conscious
there hasn't been an official
explanation from
corona as of yet but we should note that
authorities actually
have been suspecting foul play as as i
always have
[Music]
yeah i was wrong about you alcohol
i see you found a kindred spirit have
you
i'm more of a bud light lime guy oh my
gosh look i said the douche go ahead
i kind of laugh a little bit at this and
i'm sorry this may be like the dark side
of humor for me
i kind of think if we just step back let
the corona thing take its course all the
corona drinkers will be gone we won't
have to worry about it a little bit
if you drink corona this might be just
it's sort of it's sort of like vaping
batteries
yeah exactly we just step back and go
let's let nature take its course here
i really would have thought you know you
wouldn't think the explosion you would
think it's mexican tap water would be
the the
high risk factor there well that's a
good point actually
yeah montezuma's revenge i think is
something that's a real thing
yeah i thought it looked like you're
about to say something there no but i
never
i never know because you know you're
terroristy a little sh oh i was just up
to something in my mind
so shifting creativity all right turning
to big tech
uh the youtube gamer shirako am i saying
that right shiroko
why would you ask me by the way i i want
this man to be a guest in the show
so shirako however it's pronounced dude
uh
please we would welcome you he had his
channel deleted for sharing a clip in
which
he fed a suffragette feminist to an
alligator in the latest
red dead redemption 2 game you know i
can't really do it justice let's just
let's just watch
the clip this is what got him banned
here on youtube let
me vote all right it's a national
disgrace
there'll be no more wars no hunger no
stupidity
we'll elect a woman president within the
first 10 years of course
you see men are successful don't worry
it's coming guys briggs
you need us women to help straighten you
out
[Applause]
[Laughter]
get the lasso there you go i've never
played this game
but when i was watched as a non-gamer
i can't stop playing this game ah
well i don't know it gets it gets it
gets better it gets way worse
i will defend myself
oh
alligator is in ketosis i'm sure
high protein i had not played this game
and i love this game
then his youtube channel was reinstated
and i swear he actually came back in the
very first video or one of the first
videos
it's called deporting a mexican and he
played a game another thing in red dead
redemption so this guy just doesn't care
and it's a good there's actually there's
a strong debate going on in the gaming
community because if this is a violation
of guidelines on youtube then everything
is a violation of guidelines on youtube
because if you do do you have any idea
how many people you kill in these games
and most of them are men that's all you
do
you blow people's brains out you can't
if you are starting to police what
people do in video games we are screwed
because every video game out there
that's popular has stuff like that in it
or at least the ability to do stuff like
that they said it promotes violence i'm
like
what game that's fun doesn't yeah like i
don't know racing games
creative outlet racing games no that's
violence ram into people tetris
little little pollo pop hey why don't
you go
in with the helicopter going through the
maze oh good lord no no
that's true that's not very violent but
he's like in our countries
that we represent that's actually let
him say what he's saying mr obama
what were we about to say there well i
was going to express the plight of the
turtles from the mario brothers
you know you stomp on the turtles like a
bunch of savages
we would never play such a game no no
stop on those turtles what do you do
with the turtles there in uh in
syria we don't have turtles i've never
seen a turtle there really
yeah i don't know if somebody ate them
all but
that would be it so it'd be a novelty we
could we should next time having stu we
should show you that show you the
turtles i would love to see a turtle i
would love to
to go to the san diego zoo if that's
down the street or something i don't
know
no we're nowhere near yeah a little bit
of bigger landmass
you think everything's close yeah
20-minute drive i know
no it's like people with canada they
have no idea that british columbia is
nowhere near montreal
uh finally in um in in in sadder news
uh justice ruth bader ginsburg was
actually you know hospitalized for
fracturing uh some ribs in a fall
according to the statement ginsburg 85
experienced his comfort effort she was
going home
following the fall uh was admitted to
george washington university
uh thursday morning for observation and
treatment and
actually a lot of people an emt on the
scene is a mug club member
and snuck us a video of the justice uh
before bringing her to the hospital
i've fallen and i can't protect roe v
wade
it almost seems like that's distasteful
um maybe maybe a little
yeah it's just a little bit that was
fast
that was real suddenly though by the way
if ruth ruth raider ginsburg the gop
senate pickup seemed like a little bit
of a bigger win
right this is one thing we're talking
about ruth bader ginsburg have you seen
the documentary on netflix
they've been trying so hard for someone
to convince them rapping grandma
and i remember matt damon talking about
i want to see i want to see the actuary
tables and john mccain because there's a
very strong chance that he dies and
sarah palin is president with ruth bader
ginsburg or bernie sanders it doesn't
matter all of a sudden
just holding out like what is it uh
somebody said that it was like this gula
ghoulish death watch basically for the
supreme court yeah i can't remember
who's the german capiro or somebody or
no term it was herman mckay
it's absolutely that this is mr nine
nine nine that was a good daddy's pizza
it's a good
solid plan so i have a serious question
for you like i i have a big problem with
lifetime appointments for supreme court
justices for stuff just like this we get
to basically sit and watch people
wither away so they can't use it to
profiteer off hover around commercials
well
that's also true and you know
self-lubricating catheters that
yeah as well but i do have a problem
with long-term appointments i mean i i
don't think that supreme court justices
should be lifetime appointments i think
they should have a term
or something where if they get too old
we've got we've got a situation where
she's not able to really do the job
she's not able to walk apparently she's
not sleeping half the time right
asleep half the time we shouldn't have
this person up there just
dying in front of everybody we should
let them go off gracefully i don't know
that i agree but actually
we're receiving word actually right now
that the notorious ruth better
ginsburg's rib is actually not
doing so well uh yeah
[Music]
gerald seems surprised almost as though
he didn't
read the show today at all wait there's
a show
the terrorists the terrorists how are
you doing there mahmood this is live
right yeah there are no second chances
right yeah
oh my gosh okay so as it was usually you
lifetime appointments is that i want you
to finish that's pretty much i
have that's a serious point for me
though i understand i really don't think
moving on to the vox rebuttal
i'm in the waiting time move the
football right as i kick
okay no this is so but you you obviously
had some opinions on this and i had you
watch this before you came on the show
remember i sent you
this this morning yesterday we're going
to be talking about this on air yes i
watched this on my kindle fire
did you really yeah i really i don't
think you guys should do anything with
fire in the names okay burning people
alive it just kind of brings up bad
memories i think that's a brand new
it's appropriation that's i i could see
your point i could see your point
i don't know i don't i don't see his
point at all you don't have to concede
any territory yeah
you're gonna use it the terrorist is
being nicer to me than you he is
he is i have no problem with it you can
check by the way did you see the notice
that one the crazy super fan who really
loved you there at uh um
i did i did just didn't i did too i
watched you made it up no i watched
there is not one
she stopped
no because you know if she falls asleep
you can like snicker and make jokes
about her but you're still awake so we
can't make fun of
and you didn't wear the same colored
shirt as i wore today yeah finally like
three days in a row
randomly we should coordinate well he's
now now he stole quarter
black's thunder oh i did no come on
that's not even blue i'm partially
colorblind that's not the same color
i think i think uh garrett is a quarter
black and then the other three quarters
is dicky greenleaf with the short sleeve
button shirt i'll own it whatever the
mixture is it's very white so what do we
end up with
i mean it's three quarters we talked
about jim acosta we talked about dr
carlson but let's kind of get into the
realm here of of identity politics
in the wake of the blue wave as it's
been called i guess by the left
like we said see yesterday's analysis
when some loosen that's really what the
election was but in the wake of these
elections
uh people have tried to read into
something i think that isn't there
exactly and then push agendas that don't
make sense so
laying the groundwork there enter vox's
latest video
telling us all that we need to vote in
more women because
the 2018 midterms were huge for women
candidates
a total of 273 women were on the ballot
in the 2018 midterms representing both
parties
now compare that to the past five
elections that's a big jump in women
candidates vying for office
so women must be pretty well represented
in the us government now
right not exactly okay so here comes the
doom and gloop
first off before we get to rebutting
this is there not a is there not one
straight male capable of narration in
all of the vox studios nope
not one not one none of them what's the
hiring process like there
are you gay check yes or yes
do you sound a feminist right you have a
list
an add-on is latino yeah it's like the
opposite of when you purchase a gun
which by the way i'm not one who
sees racism on every rock but when you
go to when you go to purchase a firearm
are you it has caucasian black and then
it has latino and then afterwards it has
non-latino you have to check the box
specifically non-latino specifically
singles out doesn't say non-black not
work non-latino i i assume because of
illegality of citizenship
uh let's move on to the first that's not
a trick question no it really is that
literally
seriously box just one just one you
mustn't be afraid to expand your
horizons i'm sure there's a straight old
white guy there somewhere
probably the one controlling the purse
strings find him have him narrate the
next
video all right let's move on to the
clips the share of women in the house
and senate has increased over time
but it's still well below the share of
women in the u.s population
and if you dig deeper congress looks
even less representative
women of color make up 18 of the u.s
population
but before the 2018 midterms they
accounted for just
seven percent of congress it's so
boring so by the way your mic is on
while this is while the clips are going
just so you know
he gets quite like he thinks no you can
be you're not muted uh because i'm sure
everyone would love to hear your
commentary on what vox is doing
or about women and y'all's culture
typically right that's always going i'm
sorry
like i was gonna fall asleep yeah yeah
like ruth bader ginsburg and then crack
a couple you wake up like what happened
to my
ribs they elect women here i don't know
could you imagine a dinner with ruth
bader ginsburg and bernie sanders
i don't have it just it would just be
the words what for 20 minutes i could
get a trance
what what what what you filthy
[ __ ] um that's what bernie sanders
that's what he says that's what he calls
versus pet it's my pet name
it's a term of endearment i call her my
filthy fish
it's a term of endearment really
she doesn't like it much so i don't
understand the vox
video here women make up fifty percent
of the population only nine percent they
they only make up what nine percent of
construction workers yeah
who cares well and they voted they voted
for these people right
the women vote here yes they vote more
they can vote this is not like some
advanced country where that is not the
case
they voted this is who they voted if we
did because not enough stuff for jess
we're
we're fed to crocodile that's true so we
got to the point now where now everyone
can vote one at a time okay
so 50 they're like 50 percent of the
population they only make up this
percentage yeah okay they make up nine
percent of construction but they make up
75
of education health services right this
is something people go into different
fields gender i think we have an overlay
here from the
bureau and labor statistics since when
does every job have to represent a
mirror image of the census
of the united states demographics you
know what else by the way doesn't mirror
the full
eighteen percent they talk about the
women of color yeah like eighteen
percent women of uh
okay only thirty percent of black women
have high school degrees
14 have college degrees
so it would stand a reason that they
don't all make it to the highest levels
of government though 68.5 percent do
make it to the highest levels of the
wnba
yeah well look we if fox is going to be
if fox is going to be calling people out
why don't they have
a little bit more diversity on their
staff instead of gay lispy
latino males that is a very good that's
like 97 percent of their work
except i can't confirm that this guy was
latino oh i can just pretty much confirm
that yeah it sounds like including it's
not like gay dar
well i guess sonar would be yeah yeah
sonar is pretty close
yeah i'd be really sorry is usually
people usually when they're looking and
they're saying gaydar so that's not yeah
well we're hearing so that's yeah that's
like you're looking
gay vibes are coming back to you right
you're looking gay vibes are coming back
that's why
i mean what's the over under on this i
don't understand again they're just
picking something to complain about and
saying oh well they represent this
number of the population so you should
represent this percentage of the
electorate why
i i don't know why and by the way it
changes every single year
from straight mail to game not at fox
but from straight mail to gay male
from white to black from male to female
i mean you could follow a district you
could follow over the last 30 years
and you would find something different
and you certainly would find some
diversity of thought
unless it's in california or in new york
but that's what really what we should be
talking about here but again vox
just you need to vote for more women
because well why they make up 50
of the population okay
need i say more yes you do yes we're
expecting more i thought the argument
was over well no they've actually done
studies in the most egalitarian
countries in the world
these gender gaps actually spread out
further so in places where they have
the most opportunity the most equality
women tend to segregate themselves in
careers and fields and industries
more so than we see now so it's
absolutely scientifically disproven
wait what was that again so if you say
75 percent of females are in this
workforce and there's only
10 over here is engineers in the most
equal societies in the world that gap is
actually
larger it doesn't get narrow which is
what you would expect because they would
have more opportunities they can treat
it more equally
and it doesn't narrow it all it actually
gets larger because people self-select
out of these things most of the time but
we have to move on from uh from women
and black women to uh
the more the more important martial
pressing issues next clip
lgbt women make up about two point five
percent of
the u.s population don't buy it there
are only two openly lgbt women in
congress greater than sign that's less
than
one percent screwed it up by the way i
just love how they toss in the tea
and just most of the lgbt let's it's
like 90 percent g
and then so we're saying 2.5 no first
off they now they've tried it's they're
trying to say it's five percent of the
population is gay five point something
no it's it's not they just realize that
if they
keep bumping up the percentage that
people will become more embracing of the
politicians
the cultural ramifications but only two
maybe because it's weird
i challenge anybody to take a melatonin
and try to make it through this video
it is literally so boring yes the guy's
voice is pretty monotone too
that's why that's why i'm looking for
everyone here to help snap it up i've
got to deliver the information i need
you guys i need to play straight man
it probably because it's weird right we
had we had the first transgender mayor
of a texas town
on the show oh yeah and you know what
the whole time i was insane it was very
respectful
and we sat there and we talked about
sort of uh uh we went back i think to
judith butler to
fund dubai we talked about gender theory
but the whole time i'm just going in my
head
this is weird this is weird this is
weird that's all i did when i watched it
it was
very very bizarre and most people
probably
now doesn't mean that you're less than
doesn't mean that i think you should be
the victim of a hate crime
but it means that if somebody is really
weird a good example leslie in austin
people remember him he used to wear
short shorts you see his butt cheeks he
passed away was really sad he was kind
of like an austin icon right
he was no i don't know if he was
homeless there was a legend kind of
starting the point is he was weird
but people liked him they embraced him
probably wouldn't want him united said
it
that's why you've only would have
appreciated the dress i'm not mad at
leslie
you're not that leslie every town has a
leslie okay
this is uh by the way hey if you're not
a mug club member you can watch the show
every single night hit the notification
bell
if you're subscribed on youtube because
subscriptions don't show up in your
subscription box anymore
uh and uh would you recommend of course
that you join my club unless you want
the whole show to go away and uh we have
an upcoming change my mind
we might be back at tcu on monday or we
might be back there tuesday and
broadcast live
who knows tcu who knows you thought
you'd let us out in the rail but uh
that's coming soon
on baby i will say that someone might
have a case of the mondays
all right next clip take a look at this
chart
showing what 20 candidates spent time
talking about
women were much more likely than men to
discuss issues like education
climate change and minimum wage
and they're 200 percent more likely to
be blindsided by a third world war
because national security was nowhere on
that list
first off the slave handlers like
they're more likely to talk about these
issues which
right okay first off you're really
trying to straddle the fence here vox
like they're more likely to have
mentioned
these issues at one point according to
the box chart
who gives a rat's ass but let's go with
okay these are the issues that matter
most to women
climate change education minimum wage
[Laughter]
you you think this is going to convince
everyone who's what you think a chart
saying that women tend to care not about
national security not about the primary
purpose of government keeping its
citizens safe that that the fact that
they couldn't care less that that's
going to uh
i guess appeal to more voters i am i'm i
shouldn't be dumb i shouldn't say i'm
surprised or dumbfounded i'm just
disappointed
look i understand that politicians are
going to pander to their audience and
they're going to talk about the things
that are important to them but if i see
climate change and there's 50 some odd
percent of women talking about it and
not saying it's a hoax
i'm not voting for that person or at
least challenging it as being the 95 or
98
of all scientists agree kind of thing
yeah so if i see that on somebody's
talking points i'm like
i don't know if you know what you're
talking about yeah i'm just trying to
drum up votes but that's actually code
for you're gonna hit her which i don't
support oh
we we tried to uh to convince people
with pie charts and stuff like that
initially
at the beginning not that effective no
not that effective that you're a
religion of peace or
that you know we started we started hey
uh but you know uh you told me that
uh uh president ross perot oh
so he won in y'all's country today is
just a third party extravaganza
johnson he didn't have any niche with
his american political interests
all right let's let's go to the next
clip there's even evidence that women
make better lawmakers oh
one study found that female lawmakers
bring in nine percent
more federal spending for their how is
that better than their male counterparts
and that's on top of the fact that women
lawmakers sponsor more bills than male
legislators
so in case you're confused yeah vox is
saying that women make better lawmakers
exclusively because they increase
federal spending and bureaucracy in red
tape
isn't that bad also by the way snakes
make better pets because little known
fact they're more likely to bite you
think this is a selling point
and potentially kill you with venom the
brazilian wandering spider is great to
keep in your
tray because it causes pride pets i'm
leaving that you mean you mean a deathly
boner
boner spiders yeah but when you say when
you say it that way you say it like it's
a bad thing
it's a perfect example of vox right here
just assuming that everyone consuming
any and all media is a far leftist and
this is this is why i just think there's
this divide
it's not even because of people i was
trying to break down tucker carlson's
door or antifa dragging people out of
cars and beating them up
it's because of of an out-of-touchedness
a blind spot that is growing
so large i think they sat around and
said yeah we really need to get people
to vote for more women yeah let's
let's tell them that they spend more and
create more bills
and they care about climate change and
not the military
how's that not sexist we'll be able to
spend more than
that the thing with shopping okay
women's government all right listen i'll
hear you out i'll hear your case maybe
there's a case to be made here fine but
then their reasoning
is the opposite of that next clip
this success might actually help explain
why women are less likely to run for
office than men
in the first place many women
underestimate their qualifications and
perceive gender bias among voters
which discourages them because of these
hurdles only the most talented and
ambitious women
seek office
okay
these women who were elected during the
2018 midterms will help inspire other
women to run for office in the future
and as more women join government their
representation will become more and more
normalized
and eventually a video like this won't
even be necessary
it's not necessary yeah thank you it's
not necessary
hallelujah at all yeah well you know
it's almost like your job is to make vox
fun but instead you sort of just said
let's let stephen take this one
uh i have the impossible task i'm trying
i'm trying to
admit you for making me watch vox videos
i know but you can write about it every
day
play another song man that's all i got
well look i wish they would have been
supportive of women candidates i don't
know maybe when sarah palin was running
as the first
vice presidential candidate uh and
absolutely zero
no she was uh but she's uh she was a
[ __ ]
that's what i heard that's what i heard
them say right they're legitimate i'll
give you this like sarah palin's a
little
quirky for sure but they said no hold on
a second please know that was satire
gerald took whatever he's like i'll give
it to you no no don't give it to me
i don't want you to give it to me you're
gonna that was satire i do not think
sarah pale i've met the woman i've spent
time with her husband she's not a [ __ ]
good lord janice rossi is a [ __ ]
you will hang people out to try without
even realizing it
if we sarcasm now he will quote you and
like hand
this quote to your enemies so stephen
said she's a [ __ ] fine
i don't know where that was go ahead and
make your point completely
irrespective of mine sarah bailey got it
um she's not a [ __ ] obviously
but i wish that the support would have
been there i mean the only thing that
people could do when she was running for
president was make fun of her
i thought that we would have the kind of
and i don't i don't mean this in a bad
way but i thought if there was going to
be a woman card something that got women
to go out and vote
in a way that they hadn't for
republicans in a long time it would have
been the first vice presidential
candidate
that was a woman that was a female and
it wasn't the exact opposite thing
happened
yeah you know why because because she
wasn't super qualified and because john
mccain wasn't a great candidate he was
republican women this is the important
republican women actually care about
qualifications and actually care
if you represent their values now that
being said i think sarah palin would
have made a better vice president than
joe biden yes namely because she doesn't
you know molest biker children but
i think that cortez she's not qualified
yeah no she's because
that's the point no that they're
supporting her yes but that's the point
it's the same it's the same problem you
have with any conservative with any
republican
it's like herding cats that's i think it
was actually thomas soul who said that
because they're independent thinkers
they don't just support the person the
ticket no matter what women
okay republican women didn't say hold on
vagina vagina vagina
vagina buddies forever it's like a bff
locket that would be weird
it's but that's what they do with cortez
all the women it doesn't matter
that she's a crazy bug-eyed socialist
they don't care
out of the examples even that they use
in there i think they have senator
marshall blackburn staunch conservative
uh i think led the investigation into
planned parenthood uh
remember the sale of baby parts those
videos yeah and then another one of
those
examples of that is that omar lady who
is an extreme leftist muslim which might
seem
almost uh to be an oxymoron loves
abortion hates israel and
is opposed to cutting insurance payments
of of convicted terrorists you guys
is she popular over there omar yeah i
have the bumper sticker on the camera
next to gary johnson and ross perot you
know the campbell's full of stickers huh
camel's not very happy about it
because they used a nail they don't have
stick they don't have stick technology
over there and
in in syria i don't think so we're
working with that are you
are you working it out it's just it
really is remarkable to me the identity
politics that they play uh
with women they assume that everyone is
going to care just because someone is a
woman and running on their ticket
and if you don't you should care now
hold on why
because vagina you should you've you've
convinced me this is
it's like they don't even go out and
create content that's designed to
convince anybody because it assumes
everybody agrees with them you can be a
woman and be
opposed to uh abortion or at least you
know you can be a woman and be opposed
to abortion at 26 weeks like in colorado
you can be a woman by the way you can
have tits
and not want to pay a 52 income tax how
about that
right you can have ovary or you can have
a uterus
and you know what actually want a strong
national defense
you can be slightly more feminine you
can have wider bursting hips
and not want 4 000 people coming from
the honduras and a carrot invading your
country not one of them showing up
knocking on the door and getting ready
you can be a woman
and actually think all of these things
you can hold all of these values dear
but the left wants it no no hold on a
second
if you have oversized memories i think
men actually have memories
apparently uh apparently stevenson was
lactated uh that was an actual that was
actually i read a story about
men apparently can lactate but over is
it over are the memories larger on women
is that what makes oppressed i don't
know
i'm not entirely sure the biology the
point is breasts the point is you can
have breasts
a vagina and a uterus and have your own
point of view
except in the world according to vox but
this is the kind of stuff that keeps
them up at night and
we have we have more important things to
deal with
oh my goodness oh yes
the hell is
i feel uncomfortable with you here he's
gone to see 72
virgin daiquiris that sucks you're going
to see 72 limes yeah i think really 72
just means countless in your
culture doesn't it oh yeah i forgot
[Laughter]
right we have to go we have larry the
game we got coming up uh after this and
uh mahmoud ahmad everybody
[Music]
i'll let you back on this campus
i just want to you know laugh about
things every night
but
[Music]
godless abortions and god bless america
[Music]
bill cosby says that being declared a
sexually violent predator is going to
damage his reputation
not available for comment were all the
women that he raped
[Music]
hello this is canada
it doesn't stop here it's a one way it
doesn't stop
[Music]
[Music]
see that that means my shoulder's
working now look at this it's getting
i'm getting old
for those who don't know for those who
are not club members of course i uh
i fell asleep woke up with uh with
blinding shoulder pain yeah
as one does and uh now i'm fine i still
don't know exactly what happened
all right our next guest uh very excited
to have our next guest on
uh many of you know him of course as
larry the cable guy uh he was doing a
software probably pretty sure you're
hopefully you're aware his last name is
not actually the cable guy
uh his real name is dan whitney you can
follow him on the twitter at
get our don larry dan thanks larry i've
not done this
thank you for being on sir well man
thanks for having me i hope you know i
gave up a colonoscopy to do this
did you feel pretty good about it too
well i i i don't know if we can say the
same for the the the practicing
physician but who knows
you might be into some weird stuff now
is that is that dip in your mouth right
now or what is what is this going on
well i've been on a diet for a while and
i'm a sugar holic so i try not to eat
sugar so yeah i put a little levi
garrett in every now and then so i don't
have to eat sugar
okay all right you know what and you
know how that'll end up i'll probably
end up eating sugar anyway and then i
won't have any teeth so there you go
right there you go then you just end up
addicted to both sugar and
nicotine uh and the next thing you know
you're going to see it's not that big i
didn't think you could see it was in
there
i could see it yeah i could see a little
yeah i can there will now now we can see
your pores
i think now i'm just as acquainted with
you as a physician no our good friend
owen benjamin actually
he used to uh to dip and he talked about
how uh then he just had he had to stop
because he did a lot of dip
i'm a cigar guy i'm not necessarily we
didn't really know what i'm i'm a
dude i'm a cigar guy too i love cigars i
love alec bradley's i love
the anniversary padron but i got to tell
you i
quit i went i went dead stopped i just
quit
and i'm touring with foxworthy and we're
doing these things called backyard
barbecues it was being foxworthy and fog
hat and
eddie money and a marshall tucker we had
this big this big thing for
our satellite radio show and man i was
losing weight i was doing good as soon
as i walked backstage for the first one
the whole counter is donuts candies
cakes pies and i walked right out and i
told my tour manager i said bayman
go to the store right now get me a bag
of levi garrett i cannot eat this stuff
i'm doing too good in my diet
and he said yeah but you quit mr whitney
and i said i know but
i'm just going to do it when i do these
things so that i won't
so i won't eat that sugar so go ahead
and got me back and dad i got hooked on
it
two things i love about that story first
that larry the cable guy is a diva and
second that for some reason your tour
manager when you tell the story
sounds like you as larry the cable guy
you give him that character i get
confused myself sometimes
well i think it surpri might surprise a
lot of i don't think it surprises a ton
of people that listen someone from the
south leans kind of more center right
let me ask you this um as so as a
character larry the cable guy
sometimes it's easier i know when we do
characters here on the show sometimes
you feel invincible because like well
i'm not necessarily saying that but i
think it also surprised some people with
some of your tweets recently talking
about kind of comedy the state we're in
um the ability to make some cerebral
points
that maybe yeah go ahead i mean look i'm
not a look
you gotta you're not an idiot to play an
idiot i mean you gotta be pretty look at
steve martin steve martin played an
idiot great steve martin's not a dumb
guy
i'm not a dumb guy i i i love that style
of humor you know i grew
up in a real small town in southeast
nebraska
okay i'm a country kid i grew up around
livestock i was a pig i
raised hogs so it's not like i was
living in an apartment in new york or
l.a and i said you know how i can make
money i'll turn into a redneck right i
mean that's not the case i grew up that
way
and uh i moved to florida when i was 15
years old
and i started doing stand-up in my early
20s when i moved to florida i naturally
gravitated to all the florida cracker
kids
right because they grew up like i did
they grew up in the lifestyle that i
grew up in
and so when i started doing stand-up
it was regular stand up i had you know
in steve martin's book steve martin in
his book that he
i remember when he was talking about the
process of stand up and he says it takes
a good ten years
for you to really find out who you are
and to be comfortable in what you're
doing
and that's what it took for me you know
i i started doing characters and
and i did all kinds of characters and
then one night i did
this cable installer and it was funny
and i remember after i got done doing it
at the comedy corner in west palm beach
that night
david spade and rob schneider were there
and i got done doing the character and
they both came up to me said man that's
hilarious that's like that could be a
saturday night life character you should
keep working on that
and of course there's a comment coming
up i'm like man how cool is that
yeah want to make a lot to make a long
story short i don't want to bore you
with this whole thing no i'm very
interested i'm still waiting on my ten
years to get comfortable with myself so
we'll talk about that after but
some people it happens quicker but you
but some people it does most people
so uh i started uh doing the character
on uh a buddy of mine's radio station in
tampa 95 ynf
it was hilarious it was really popular
uh then i got syndicated into some other
markets and and steve when i
when i tell you this is a fact i never
meant to ever do it
on stage it was theater of the mind
yeah it was radio um i was always a fan
of the show all in the family
sure all right rg was hilarious
and the show was hilarious well i
understand you're experimenting and then
sometimes something kind of becomes your
calling card i mean for example i never
expected to actually interview
wendy davis as a [ __ ] on the state
capitol it just happened because she was
like oh this would be a great photo op
my wig and hat blows off i'm going on my
cover's blown
and it became one of the most iconic
moments in all of this program's history
because
how did you get so i'm like she invited
me over um
no but i i you've had some great tweets
lately kind of because the left has come
out and talked about how
a right-leaning perspective cannot be
funny or they just don't understand the
medium of comedy
uh which of course i disagree with um
tell us a little bit more about kind of
kind of your tweets for people who
aren't necessarily uh
in the know aren't following you and
what your reaction happened
i definitely will look can i finish my
other thing yes sorry go ahead
so anyway to make a long story short um
uh
a buddy might build me as dan whitney
aka
larry the cable guy at his comedy club
one night in uh
florida and i went on stage and the
larry the cable and i was doing fine i
mean i was a funny comedian
but the larry stuff just killed and so
he came up to me i couldn't follow it i
you know i tried to go back into my own
accent i couldn't really follow
people are yelling you know that you're
dead yeah i get done i'm signing
autographs i'm taking pictures and my
real name's on the board it says
dan whitney aka larry the table guy
right people are coming up boy larry we
just love you we just left
and so he came up to me and he said you
know what i'm going to erase your name
and i'm just going to leave larry the
cable guy up he goes can you do your
whole show like that and i said
look i talk like that all the time with
my buddies because all my buddies are
super southern so we just talk like that
yeah so i went on stage the second show
and i did my entire show like that
and pretty much the rest is history i
ended up syndicating myself on 27 radio
stations across the country
people always say he came out of nowhere
he was an overnight
sensation but that goes back to what
steve martin said it takes a good ten
years
i did i called radio stations
five days a week every day for 13 years
yeah and i developed an audience and so
that's how my career happened now
with your question about what i was
tweeting out i always get irritated
comedy is so subjective obviously
it's subjective it's like soda pop
there's different flavors and
you can like a flavor and not like a
flavor but i always get a little
irritated when i see people come just
flat out on the internet
first of all they don't know anything
about the business and they go there's
not one funny conservative
commit conservatives just aren't funny
there's no
funny conservative comedians and even
when you present them with facts and the
way i say
facts is here's how you can determine
uh who how a comedian is successful
um by the free market right the free
market
dictates who they think is funny and who
they think isn't funny
and if you go by the free market
there's a lot of funny conservative
comedians out there
and i even i even text out you know sen
they put out on the internet a few years
ago the top 20
selling comedy artists in the history of
the sound scan
era now this is factual these are album
sales
yeah concert draws and the very first
line
is the blue color comedy tour
dominates 10 of the 20 spaces right
and even when you say and and not only
that adam sandler was on there who's
definitely
a conservative type comedian sure uh
jerry clower was on there so
when you look at the facts obviously
there are
funny concerns i think and this lends
itself kind of kind of what else you
were talking about uh
and where they sort of leverage this the
media right now you talk about netflix
and hulu and amazon prime it's really
dominated now it's
become kind of like three main networks
again and they're actively pushing again
they're not going to include a lot of
conservatives typically we've had people
on the show who've talked about that
uh what was this just nanette was a
recent special what she said
i'm not going to do jokes because
there's nothing funny about being
humiliated
actually there's there's a ton funny
about being humiliated i get humiliated
all the time it depends on how you look
at it
uh the industry is trying to manipulate
the free market in a lot of ways like
owen our good friend you know we've lost
agents and management
um how do you how do you view that do
you think that these gatekeepers are
going to go away as we continue down the
trail
well i you know i i have no idea
i i just always i've always just thought
that the free market
is where you get your reward if you're a
comedian i mean
jeff foxworthy told me a long time ago
jeff taught me so much
and stand up and you know one of the
things that jeff always told me was show
business is called
show business for a reason everybody
likes to do the show
nobody likes to do the business right
there's a lot of people funnier than me
there's a lot of people funnier than
jeff
but there was nobody better at the
business than me and jeff
and uh so if you're good at the business
the show part's gonna come
yeah and so i always learn that from
jeff but jeff always told me this too he
said look
you're uh don't ever he told me right
off the bat he said don't ever
expect to win any kind of
award from uh
from your peers um because
you're all you're already coming out
doing a southern character and
uh they for some reason
hollywood does not like that and the
proof
is in the pudding because you know jeff
has sold more albums than bill
cosby and richard pryor combined plus he
hasn't raped anything
and he's never that as well
and he never ever has won a grammy award
for his albums i mean yeah there was
nobody
nobody even touches jeff i mean jeff was
selling every album he put out he was
selling two
three million copies yeah i know he's
never won it so
when people say to us you're never gonna
win anything like that
i always say it doesn't matter the proof
is in the free market
right and one thing with comedy that's
so that's so like you talk about being
subjective that really is so volatile i
remember when i was doing an uh i don't
know if you probably don't remember this
naca conference when i was starting in
stand-ups this is a national oh yeah
oh my gosh this is a hell of a carrot
top made of killing he did make a
killing and i got
murdered i remember i went i went out
there and i was canadian
uh at this point i was 18 i think my
first nacca and
i was always i've always been inherently
conservative right i didn't picture
myself as a political comedian but i was
always politically increa and i went out
and had some material i think i had some
jokes about about
islam and you could hear the audience
get really offended and i remember i was
brought backstage afterwards like yeah
you can't you can't do this here at naca
but i remember someone was telling me at
that point they were talking about how
you were
the biggest name in comedy i heard these
i won't talk about them publicly but the
numbers that you were getting paid for
every show and i was like oh my god i
couldn't even possibly imagine that
i remember before that was was it was
kind of dane cook uh and then for a
while was you know you have amy schumer
kevin hart but really when you look at
steve martin it does seem like comedians
stick around for a very very long time
obviously and they have their audiences
right but the person who is number one
it's like the heavyweight championship
it's really hard to hang on to that spot
it's usually not more than
a year or two and then they come back
around it's it's uh
is that something for you that was ever
difficult to kind of deal with these
these like i said the volatility the
variance there from year to year
well you know i was always i mean i
liked
everybody i mean stephen i mean i've
gotten along with
obviously i'm a conservative comedian
but i've gotten along with
all sorts of comedians i mean i'm
friends with louis black
and i'm friend you know i'm friends with
tom my buddy tom ryan is a super lefty
and
sure i mean i'm ton i'm i'm friends with
a lot of comedians that i don't agree
with but
i'm a guy that loves the craft of comedy
i'm a one-liner comedian i was a fan of
all the old guys coming up so i do a lot
of one-liners
but i'm a fan of the craft and i'm one
of those guys that
i may not agree with your politics
matter of fact i may hate your politics
and if you have a show i probably won't
watch it
but i find you funny you do things that
are funny because i love the
the way you constructed the joke and so
i've always been like
that way too except but my philosophy is
i just if you want to masturbate in the
green room i'm not going to watch it you
know that's kind of a hard line for me
that i set
um right well a lot of people have to
set certain things right we have to set
certain boundaries healthy boundaries
last question
everyone's mind that we of course cannot
talk about but uh it
occurred after we originally spoke about
you coming on uh the program
uh you've been in the national news
recently for a story that you probably
didn't want to be
when you saw these uh images where you
when you read the news were you
surprised
well i was surprised it made me sad it
made me angry
and uh you know and they said that uh
you know and i gotta say that there was
they had like a getter done somebody put
well get her done on one of those
things that were sent out in the mail
and uh first it wasn't spelled right
first of all
right um uh the guy i don't think get
her done is usually spelled right so at
that point it's
obvious
it just frustrates me and irritates me
whoever does anything like that is
pathetic and they should spend the rest
of their life in jail but
i you know i the my phrase get her done
has been around
i've been saying it since i had a
copyrighted 91
and it's been used from everybody from
little league baseball teams to football
teams
to kids in hospitals i don't know how
many times
that's been the rallying cry in cancer
hospitals for these kids
but it's a great phrase it's a fun
phrase it's intended to be
uh empowering for people that are
that are in situations and uh i'm not
going to let anybody
uh hijack that phrase that phrase
we've raised a lot of money for good
offering right don't let that guy
appropriate okay
we don't we don't want to continue on
that because i don't give them any more
attention than it's worth but it was it
was listen it was the elephant in the in
the outside the envelope that we had to
address
it is at get our done larry uh
dan whitney uh aka the cable
gator well i know but people will
misspell it get
r done larry dan thanks so much for
being here brother and uh be well i
appreciate your wife her phone back
essence you stole it for the technology
i'll do it steven i appreciate you man
thank you thanks man take care and we'll
be back after this to wrap this up in a
nice
[Music]
with
ripping
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh hello thinking of joining mug club
don't mug club is terrible
it's 250
that's not an accurate price point at
all ah no
no it's not i think i would have thought
you'd do better prop again i really was
hoping for some propaganda
hopefully you don't pull out the deer
knife but okay okay 250
but you get a mug and that is all yeah
no
you get a lot more than a mug actually
you not only get the show every single
day but uh
you also get every single show on cr tv
yeah the whole catalog the whole
that's not 250. it's right 669 for
students veterans active military
lottery credit.com
mug club yeah uh i'm not a rocket doctor
but that sounds like
250 it does not sound like 250 it is
surprisingly affordable and
it's what allows us to keep doing this
show uh every single day and uh things
like change my mind crowder confronts uh
you know all the things that you've come
to know and love but if you don't want
them that's okay
we can just have a mammoth mamu take
over because i'm pretty sure that he's
in a panel somewhere some kind of a
board with susan wojcicki what's she
like by the way
uh i who literally dot com slash mug
club
stephen
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that was called the uh the cocky diver
with no tolerance for cold who didn't
realize that there was an uh
undercurrent
if you go back and watch it you
understand it makes perfect sense it's a
long it's a long name for a dance uh
thank you to
the cable guy being on the show and uh
thank you so much to my mood alma mood
we actually had to have him
escorted by armed security yeah had to
bring him in as a whole big though uh
speaking of security uh changed my mind
uh next week
could be live broadcast from tcu on
monday or tuesday was maybe when we're
gonna go there and show up who knows
who knows the chalk doesn't lie but the
chalk is very non-specific
um very vague yeah
i would have been very vague by saying
maybe we'll be descending up on the
campus monday or tuesday
um so a couple we are by the way you
know we've gone through the golden
ticket sweepstakes
uh and i should also say we're not doing
a show the thursday of thanksgiving for
people before people
send their youtube videos put that out
there don't use this next email
that i'm going to release here to send
your complaints we always get that when
we talk about oh we're hiring
here's where you send your email you're
like hey i think that you should do this
i want this is not really what it's for
like here's a picture of my penis and
like hold on a second are you a fox news
staffer and it always turns out they are
um so we are hiring people right now
this is something that i want to make
sure we're very very specific
so follow these instructions here uh
this comes to me from smooth manny who
is
in charge of the edit bay we're hiring
one person right now
uh main qualities expert in photoshop
also after effects and premiere
uh it needs to be a mastered image comp
color correction particularly something
i don't know what photo bashing is
exactly but i know that
it's a thing you need to know um
obviously you have to be a fan of the
show
familiar with the show have a congruent
sense of humor uh
timing and story flow through video
editing and creative choices so
the reason we're being very specific
here is because a lot of the times
people send an email go i have no
qualifications i can't do any editing
but i really like the show can i work
there
was like i appreciate but we can't
necessarily hire you uh we will have
some pa positions opening up
soon and that's something that if you're
less skilled in editing or you're less
seasoned
we bring in a lot of people as a matter
of fact you were effectively at piano
first
for a while you moved your way up i
climbed um something else you must be
willing to relocate
and soon if not don't waste the
wonderful staff's time here because they
had to relocate they're in charge of
relocating people
if you don't have to be where the studio
is located uh
so if it's like ah well i will i not
relocate then this probably isn't the
position for you
you must be able to work under tight
deadlines work this is still i'm still
maining you here someone uh puts it
making it
this is this is the most difficult
possible scenario because we don't want
you to
we have too many we have like hundreds
and hundreds of resumes from the last
time so
we're trying to filter this out because
we want to find the right person to help
the folks there in the edit page tight
deadlines uh work well with others be
capable of implementing constructive
criticism
and listen work long and hard until the
project is done this isn't the same
it's not like most workplaces there
aren't weekends if a project is not done
because
people want to kill you so if all of
this still sounds like you
this is what you need to do you need to
send an email to i am your expert
at louderwithcrowder.com you are to
title your email
i am the expert you seek dash
2378 the numbers so again quote
this is exactly what you said i am the
expert you seek dash the number is two
three seven eight
uh include some sample photoshops or
examples of your incredible photo
bashing skills long-term resume
uh real or portfolio if you're mainly a
photoshop expert and three reasons why
you should be hired above
everyone else failure to do so failure
to do any of the follow any of these
instructions will result in immediate
dismissal of your submission
so what you will find it will yes and
courtney will find courtney carney was
also very specific she's like
i don't want to look through 500 more
resumes
and i just if i see an if i see another
dick pic
i'm like i'm sorry courtney that you had
to go through that should put a filter
we should put a filter on those pa
don't include any weird images of
yourself actually do
but don't send it here send those to
courtney specifically um slide into the
dms so we do have a busy week next week
we do have we have a uh
another life advice program uh that will
be occurring and i change my mind like
we talked about
and this is something actually i had um
kind of this is the last segment of the
week which we often
don't i don't even know it became crap
was it credit closes that was close
uh it's just something that we've done
for a long time the last time of the
week is kind of an opportunity to talk
with you guys and
and hopefully offer something a little
more earnest that that uh other shows
don't necessarily do
um this is something actually asked for
i have this book marked
on my computer uh and i'm actually
going forward and i'm gonna have this
framed in my office
and it might seem a little dark it's
actually a daily beast article it was at
the front page
it was called the unmaking of a
conservative pundit
and it was it was it was a hit piece it
was a hit piece it was a uh
caitlyn dixon wrote it caitlyn dixon
wrote this unmaking of a conservative
pundit at daily beast one of the biggest
news websites at the time
uh and i remember her this is when i
learned about journalism too
where things that i thought were off the
record were ended up being on the record
and this was entirely written to uh i
don't know why it was written you know i
was a kid
and i had left fox and we kind of
separated and it wasn't it wasn't as
looking back things weren't handled
right and there was a non-compete and
and which they were right to enforce um
i didn't really know what i was doing
but i know i remember how
down i felt um
because at that point all of it what was
written here too
was mostly real so imagine you're me
you're a kid and someone goes on one of
the biggest news websites and the one
writes
the unmaking of a conservative pundit
just talking about what a failure you've
uh become it i just remember how deeply
it stung it was something i didn't
really like to talk about for a while
so before this show would have existed
or us we were about to cross over the
three million subscriber mark
uh it would be something that if anyone
even brought up would sting and i i
don't really want to talk about that and
that's one thing i will say i appreciate
about
about president donald trump because he
he has these hit pieces all the time
doesn't care he just keeps i think he's
wrong a lot of time but
he keeps going screw them is his
philosophy which sometimes is correct
that's going to be the theme of this
credit card is screw them
so i remember actually too this spurred
an argument with my parents
which i think many of you have probably
had um i remember my parents talking
about you know
we were talking about god we're talking
about kind of christian theology and i'm
not i'm not a prosperity gospel guy
where it's like god wants you to have a
million dollars
in a g7 i don't know if it happens to g6
no that's not what i'm talking about i
remember my parents
how good god wanted good things for me
and uh i was i was better this was the
point my life was pretty bitter and i
remember i pointed all the successful
evil people in the world
and not just the saddam husseins and the
bin ladens but like even the alec
baldwins of the world i remember using
him as a specific example because sure
enough i just watched the edge again
very recently
uh and i was like well listen you know
god if you say that good guys end up
doing well for god wants good things for
them what about what about the saddam
hussein what about
like alec baldwin he's one of the most
successful actors right at this point 30
rock was really big he's
you know alec baldwin we know he's a
piece of crap
and uh my pan i remember it didn't
matter what they said they wouldn't
convince me that i was wrong but now
that i've grown up i have realized how
wrong i was
because the truth is that you don't
really know uh
what somebody else's life is i don't
remember who said this but ugly things
happen in pretty houses
let me ask you this would you trade your
life with alec baldwin's i think what is
he on marriage number
three now i believe estranged from his
daughter a lot of these celebrities how
often do you see a starlet who has it
all right you see this all the time and
we see that we envy is like we talk
about the left is really
they they cloak envy as empathy
and i think it's one of one of the most
common human traits it's the one that we
need to guard our heart against probably
the most is envy
uh i know certainly myself i can't speak
for anybody else i know it's something
that comes very naturally to be envious
how often do we see someone
i don't know a starlet or a star you
know oh man they have it all and well
all of a sudden
they go to rehab some kind of substance
abuse or you see the perfect couple
right
how many benefits have there been now
and then bang domestic abuse or they get
divorced
you don't know what their life is really
like and here's something else just as
surely you don't know how your
story ends and at this time this article
uh when it was written i didn't and the
show that you see didn't even exist the
pre daily show remember
never daily that didn't even exist and
not only is there something you know
there's
there's self-doubt that everybody has
but this journalist
i learned the hard way this journalist
this authority figure
was publicly declaring me to be a
wash-up
so i have the self-doubt going like
maybe man you're 20 you're 25 and you've
you've peaked
i don't know if you i don't know what
you go from and then someone else is
saying hey
the whole world front page he's peaked
he's done down for the count front page
what does that do that creates more
self-doubt and it's a cycle
and yes this writer sucks uh but i i
just
just
like i can't control exactly what
everyone else does with their lives
all i can control all you can control is
breaking the cycle for yourself only you
can break that cycle
there's nothing more crushing i will
tell you that's why i have this here and
that's why i will have it framed in my
office to remind me there's nothing more
crushing
than having someone else publicly
confirm your
self-doubt you can take it to a smaller
maybe i don't know you're you're
self-conscious about your weight and
someone tells you to get on a treadmill
you fat bastard
i had that once in grade school uh that
great school uh what's eighth grade here
what is it junior high junior high is i
don't know i have no idea i don't know
the school system maybe you have a
terrible zit and you go to a party and
someone says
yo what's that is this the costume party
i had that exact thing i had such a
bedside in my channel this girl asked me
if i fell off my bike
and i said yeah and you could see my
soul
leave my body you could if you if you
had if you had an ultra slow-mo camera
you could probably see the moment where
my heart
broke snapped in half like ralph from
the simpsons it's crushing it can be
absolutely crushing if someone else
confirm
something you're self-conscious about
some something that you have self-doubt
about
if you let it or you can choose
screw them maybe it's deeper than that
maybe it's deeper than a zitter weight
i'm just trying to kind of ease us
into this maybe a self-doubt that you
think you're undeserving of a good life
maybe you've achieved something pretty
great
and secretly maybe deep down you think
you're not good enough
and someone comes along and says man
she's she's way out of your league she's
not sticking around
a lot of us encounter i've encountered
that as well by the way i won't say
they're entirely wrong you can let it
crush you or you can say
screw them maybe you break off from the
world's most successful cable news
channel as a
and you're filled with crippling fear
and doubt because you don't know the
next step
and then maybe a front page journalist
declares you dead to the world
you can let it crush you and for a while
i did i had a pity party or
you can choose to say screw them and you
know what it could happen again tomorrow
i can get banned we saw this with a you
thank god the youtube
feminist crocodile feeder i don't know
if that's the term god got his channel
back
i could get banned tomorrow torch the
pitchfork mod could come for us i know
it happens
i they could have doa it'll hurt
but screw them make no mistake right now
when everyone else i think this is why i
talk about this often when they're
calling for civility
and they're calling for unity uh i'm not
i'm not calling for violence i'm not
calling for rudeness but i am calling
for everyone who's out there
who's been silent or who's scared or
who's been mocked
or intimidated who's been accused i
don't know of being a gang rapist
you don't need to hold hands and sing
screw them you can choose to say screw
them i would say that if someone accused
me of being a gang rapist
you don't have to be on board you don't
have to find unity with people
whose sole purpose in life is to crush
your spirit and here's what why do you
say scripture because you do need to
have you do need to have wise counsel
we've talked about this a lot you have
people around you who you trust
people who will offer you genuine
criticism so when you're wrong people
will call you on it
but the reason you have that closed
circle is so that you don't listen
to all of the voices that don't matter
and you shouldn't listen to them why
because your story isn't over yet
and here's the thing everyone out there
to some degree or another is great at
something i've talked about that
find what it is that you're great at
doing you are destined for great things
it may not be what you think is great it
may not even be something that you're
anticipating i may not even be on your
radar but you're destined to do
something big
god wants good things for you okay you
can say the universe wants good things
for your tantric yogi instructor for all
i care wants good things for you but the
world
needs good things from you i need good
things for you this entire team
needs good things for you and we'll both
be damned all of us be damned to hell if
you're going to let somebody else
pin your last chapters i remember this
happened and it stung
so badly picture you're that kid you're
going man i don't know i don't know what
i can do for the rest of my life i've
got nine months here where i've got to
sit and just kind of steal on this
decision and hope that i stepped out in
faith and hope that it's right and
someone calls up and says hey you know
what i'm doing a piece of profile piece
on you
uh can we talk about some things say oh
yeah i guess so sure
yeah this will be off the record and
then the undoing
undoing unmaking of a conservative
pundit
goes on to a news site that you read
every single day
that sucks it sucked and i keep it there
because you know what i keep it
in front of me and i i read it regularly
you know why
because i go back to oh wait hold on a
second there was a stage in my life
where
i thought this person was right
and they weren't i was letting that
person write the next chapter to my life
you don't have to do that
you can choose to let someone else not
only dictate the next chapter of your
life
not only write the next portion of your
book but you can choose to let someone
stop you from writing it yourself don't
you can also choose
screw them that's okay there's nothing
immoral about that it's certainly not
any less virtuous in this idea of unity
out there that we try we try to faint as
though we're gonna find common ground
with people who want us dead with people
who want us completely incapable
of seeking gainful employment they will
people who want the world to think that
we're gang rapists
no no no i think that you sit down
determine what you want in life
chart of course make a plan and if the
people don't fit in with that plan if
these people are trying to stop you from
reaching your goal guess what it's okay
for you to say
screw them that's it that's the message
this week i'll see you next week i think
it's a monday or tuesday
[Music]
night
[Music]
you